[Music]
how old were you guys
when you guys became independent from
your parents
five five independent i think i was uh
18. yeah what do you mean
what do you mean by independent yeah i
oh what the hell i don't [ __ ] listen
to you i do my own [ __ ] but i still need
money every night
you don't need money the only money
ah yeah money that's the same money is
kind of like the basis for
this experiment 17 18 i ran away and
started selling drugs at 14.
and you never went back to your mom for
money or a couple months
and then yeah it's young i don't know
which came first my dad left or that
happened first and then i came back
because i had a place to sleep i think
25 or 26 25 26
17 because they supported me through
college yeah so technically like true
yeah that would that would count
25 26 i got no support true what about
you tiffany i was about 16
16 yeah cause that's when i got my first
job and
even before 16 though i almost never
asked my mom for money that's why i like
i was that kid that annoying kid during
lunch time i'd be like
can i borrow a quarter and i'd ask
everyone to borrow a quarter
to make a dollar 25 and i could buy
lunch every day
and so i owed a [ __ ] ton of people money
did you pay them back i did i tried my
best to pay them back
so whenever i was in high school like i
guess that was the time i did ask her
for
money to pay people back which yeah i
don't know you're like mom
i need 648 quarters
oh no you know what i did i just
remembered oh this is bad i feel bit i
felt bad
so myself i feel bad so my stepdad used
to have the
because there was like this decorative
vase kind of thing it was really it was
pretty tall
and he would throw his change in there
all the time and
i would just go in there and get the
quarters and that's how i would pay
people back
why would you feel bad because that's
technically stealing well you know what
i would say
it's family community money yeah i got
it there we go
that's good oh cause i saw that as
stealing that's why i felt
it was stealing but like if would it
make you feel better if every kid
did that i didn't do that right i never
stole from my parents ever
yeah i never stole my friends stole for
me and then they said
what you're not gonna eat it and i'm
like well it's stolen and they're like
does it change the taste of the
chocolate and i'm like nope and they're
like
well what's up then and i said thank you
[Laughter]
like you're right here never stole
nothing from your parents never ever
ever
ever not once let's try it tomorrow
we're good
try what tomorrow just do oh yeah no one
not even
like a cookie piece of candy no because
it wasn't considered stealing it's
communal or even like sticking your
finger in the cake
just to get the whipped cream no not
that's not stealing though
you never open up my mom's wallet pulled
out 40 bucks i bought a walkman
me neither it was a cd player i had
dignity
i begged wow nice how old were you when
you became completely independent
probably like 21 21 same thing with
college i feel like i was still being
able to come home
you know and at least eat food or like
sometimes ask my mom to do laundry
but then once i i think was like living
off campus apartments and stuff or like
just graduated
it was like if i was going to come home
i need to bring money
dude that just reminded me my mom
actually accused me of selling drugs
because i never asked her for money she
thought that that's how i was getting
money oh [ __ ] yeah
it's like the audacity even though i was
selling drugs i can't believe she asked
me
no i wasn't you should have i was like
man i i could have made
way more money you coulda but no i
wouldn't believe she didn't
say you're are you selling [ __ ] it's
like
only fans now everyone's like are you
selling [ __ ]
uh that's the kind of talks that parents
are gonna have to have with their kids
these days
you know what i mean and then they're
gonna be like but mom i make way more
money without
school loans yeah they're like i make a
hundred grand a month there you go right
anyways so in italy uh there has been a
landmark ruling in the italian supreme
court
uh ruling against the appeal of a 35
year old man
who was still expecting financial
assistance from his parents
at the age of 35. what a loser
what a [ __ ] loser big time did you
get laid at all
probably i don't i i wish i had a photo
there's no name for this guys i
i don't even know like gilbert what he
looks like i wish i could
all the gilbert massimo that seems very
i thought massimo was a surf brand oh it
is it's an apparel brand
at target yeah that's target target is
it massimo
is it italy i don't know what i thought
you said it was italian
yeah mario i don't know about tobias
though okay tobias
antonio is this [ __ ] face like i demand
my allowance mom and dad i'm taking you
to court
pretty much take care of me so he is a
he's a musician
and he works as a part-time music
teacher at earning
about 24 000 a year what but
he's still asking for financial
assistance from his parents
uh and then the initial ruling though on
this was
in tuscany uh they granted him 360
dollars
of a month a monthly allowance from his
parents so
at one point he was ordered uh the
parents were ordered to pay his
their son 360 a month but then it was
overturned
after an appeal was made by the supreme
court in italy
and now they are no longer required to
support their son
wow basically the son is not satisfied
with his career
the son is kind of like that's his fault
he doesn't want to be a music teacher he
wants to be a musician
and so well that's his fault he sucks
exactly how come the judge is like
this is the waste of time give us a call
out here
how many times a rock band come out of
italy
you stupid oh how many heavy mega bands
come out of italy huh
that's true we are a mafia not a heavy
metal
that's true yeah so the judge maria
cristina
she says reducing his adolescent
ambitions
uh the adult child is bound to find a
way to self-support himself
self-support himself that's so redundant
to self-support himself wait
take it back adult child is that like an
actual term
is it this is she like you don't yeah
yeah man baby a man the baby
man baby baby mentally challenged
i don't exactly make sense then i don't
think i mean he's a music teacher he
just sounds like everyone that has grown
up kind of like he's entitled yeah he
wants to do what he wants to do
but he hasn't put in the work to
actually get there so he's actually not
grateful for the second job that he has
either
yeah and he's blaming the world because
he's a failed [ __ ]
that can't do well yeah it sounds like
hey since i don't have my dream job yet
of being a real
musician why don't you you know give me
a monthly allowance while i work this
part-time teaching gig and then
you know he's just kind of he's biting
his time and he's he's he feels
interesting
it's time to 35 at 35 yeah it's a little
35
i'm not even 35 holy [ __ ] yeah this
guy's [ __ ] old
35 35
31 i think back i'm like yeah at that
age
i was probably this way that way but i'm
like i'm not even there yet oh [ __ ]
all right blew my mind yeah he's older
than you yeah i feel that
the parents that enable these kind of
dudes
they should kind of pay because they
didn't set them up to be a [ __ ] man
true you got you got to be like my mom
and up and leave
out of nowhere that [ __ ] made me a
man
in seven years how old were you when
your mom just up and left
because this is the pointy one for seven
years of being an adult
based on what you were saying earlier
yeah 21. that's not funny
i would have held on
to the free rent and live with my mom
for the rest of my [ __ ] life if i
could because
i lived free i didn't live like you know
like people want to run away from their
parents
she was the dopest roommate man like
she'd be like you hungry i'll go get
some taco bell i'm like [ __ ] yeah mom
i'll hook you like i'll hook you up you
want me to go get some groceries
and we just chill and watch we both
don't understand korean but we both
watch korean dramas and we try to figure
out what the [ __ ] is happening
like she listens to my problems and [ __ ]
she was the dopest roommate
i bring girls over we [ __ ] whatever
she's like make sure they're not hookers
and i'm like how dare you
assume that i can't get [ __ ] on my own
and you think that they're hookers
yeah and i'm like are they your
girlfriend because i don't see you with
just one
and she's like that's not good she's
sharp she knows yeah and i'm all like
you're right and then i started having
one steady girlfriend that lived with me
and she treated her like her own
daughter my mom was [ __ ] dope
that's why it was like i don't want to
[ __ ] leave the situation
but my grandma got alzheimer's and that
[ __ ] ruined everything for me
she was like forgetting she was like my
mom visited her in japan and she's all
like
yeah grandma's [ __ ] up huh and i'm
like yeah she was taking walks
leaving the stove on and when she came
back she would blame the stove like
these things are just turning on by
themselves
and i'm like that's you you dumbass
[ __ ] you [ __ ] try to make miso soup
made half of the soup
[ __ ] went on for a walk and also she
would get lost on walks
so my mom was like i need to get my ass
over there i'm like i get it
but at the time i made enough to where i
could pay for the apartment
and i made double what she did because i
had an ebay business plus
um what do you call it like i was
working a nine-to-five job
so i was a a freeloading rich man
and it's a good way to put it yeah i was
a freeloading 21 year old that was
making like
eight g's a month so it was really
[ __ ] good times i was just saving
money
i just kept building with my buddy and
it was like it was really fun times
and then boom like that i was like yeah
just go to japan i could take care of
myself
as soon as she left my house was a
[ __ ] junkyard
i didn't know how to clean it you guys
remember i remember
i didn't know how to clean she never
taught me she never taught me how to do
laundry
none of that [ __ ] and it took me years
to learn how to be an adult
it looked like you were still moving i
was like are you moving you're like no
i've been here
as soon as she left my whole house
turned into like the jk office
think about that dude we had a lot of
fun though it's funny because he's like
i had to learn how to be an adult and
i'm looking at him where he is right now
like i don't know if he learned anything
yet
i'm like when she leaves i think i'm
still the same
but yeah so this decision in italy it's
gonna they're
expecting it to have a great effect on
most of the population because
it's been a phenomenon especially in
italy
uh to have manche children uh
still living with their parents and
being uh so this is a huge this is a
huge thing that's happening in italy
yeah they even have a term for it so for
parents uh with
kids in their thirties they're called
bam bamboo
no bambino let me ask you guys something
what do you
what do you think it is about eating
pizza that makes man babies
wait is it the shape of it you think no
because i mean like that's all they eat
out in italy right it's
just one item one thing [ __ ]
neapolitan pizzas right yeah
they don't have like spaghetti no it's
only pizza that's americanized bro
i'm talking about real italy oh have you
even been there bro
yeah no i haven't either okay
you've been there more than he has well
i mean yeah they only eat pizza there
exactly so there's something in the
sauce
right that makes them a [ __ ] oh yeah
thank god we don't have anyone in italy
watching or else i will say though
just because we're talking about italy
has the best cuisine in all of europe
yeah i agree what is it pizza pizza yeah
pizza pizza is pretty good really
italian italian
cuisine all of that pizza is just so
good
so good yeah so i'll leave you with this
bamboo
uh bambiocione uh the
who is this person the italian
association of lawyers in italy
uh they said italian young people and i
i would say this is just
for people in general uh must be more
courageous must find the will to take
risk
but that's difficult if your mom keeps
bringing you a cup of coffee to bed
every morning so the cuddling this is
the coddling yeah
so i think i think even in america we
have this problem too but i miss it when
my mom cuddled me man
you know this yeah but i was forced to
be a man i don't like this [ __ ]
you're doing a good job man there we go
you know and i want you to know that you
should i want to be a millennial like
everybody else i don't like to be
different
you're not though apparently
[Music]
you
[Music]